all right
all right like yes Blake uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally I
am from Fresno California which is up
north a little bit from here about four
or five hours
tell me about your family growing up you
had both your with yourself so I am the
oldest of uh three boys uh
I'm 29 years old my middle brother's 26
years old and my youngest brother is 22
years old currently going to college at
uh Santa Clara to become a lawyer
yeah are you the black sheep of your
family you know I would definitely call
myself the black sheep and I would also
call myself the scapegoat you know
growing up I learned about all those
different uh profile types as different
as we play different roles throughout
our family and the more and more I read
about it
um you know my family kind of always
used me as an excuse to uh I was the
troublemaker you know and they always
use that as an excuse to kind of
point the finger at me but I would
definitely say I uh I earned that role
you know it's nothing that they did and
I definitely
yeah I played that role well I played
that role well I almost I owned it you
know after a certain amount of time you
think it was just something you
having your DNA and your personality no
naturally or something happen no there's
something specific that happened you
know when I was 16 years old I happened
to buy weed at school one time and uh
something happened where the kid I
bought weed from he uh got caught and I
got called into the office and my
principal asked me did you buy weed at
school yes or no tell me the truth and
I'll never forget this moment because
this moment of my life was a Tipping
Point he said look you could either deal
with me and I'll help you or you could
deal with the cops and so of course a
young kid you know I was scared I got
caught buying weed at school I told him
look to the principal I did it I did buy
weed at school and I'd much rather deal
with you than the police well instead of
helping me
he actually lied to me he immediately
kicked me out of school as a sophomore
in high school
and at the time getting kicked out of
school my dad had no idea that I had
started doing drugs or smoking weed my
dad was devastated I'll remember the
first time when he came into the office
that day he put his head down on the
office table and started crying and
asked why did you do this
and
what's the reason I'm telling the story
like that because there's one theme that
I always learned from that moment
forward is that you never tell the truth
to the authorities that's just kind of
something that was told to me
taught to me at a young age at that
moment the first time I ever told the
truth was the last time I ever told the
truth because when I did it it
immediately got me kicked out of school
and
and they they lied they they said they
wanted to help me and they didn't you
know and so from that moment
moving on you know
um I then went to continuation school
which is a school in Fresno called
Gateway and Gateway is not a normal high
school it's a continuation school for
all the kids who get kicked out of high
school and so that
I was going to school now high school
once a week only on Wednesdays I would
have to go to actually show up in a
classroom and all the other days I was
doing work online this allowed for me to
start smoking weed all the time
and hanging out with kids who got kicked
out of school as well for doing similar
things
and so the ball kind of got rolling
uh
for me to be that scapegoat me to be
that Troublemaker like I always you know
like I said I always owned up to
yeah
you graduated eventually so uh from
there okay
um from there I went back to high school
my junior year and uh something I didn't
mention yet but since a young age since
the age of about nine years old I've
played baseball very competitively I was
on the best travel ball team in Fresno
called the Twin City twins that's from
the age of nine to about 12. I was on
the River Park All-Star Little League
team which was the first team in Fresno
to ever go to the actual Little League
World Series that's on on television
that you watch you know we were on
television and we were the first team
from Fresno to ever do that and my high
school that I went to which is a school
called Clovis West in Fresno their
division one uh program and they have a
very good sports program so I went back
my junior year to a baseball team that
was one of the best baseball teams in
the nation and I was one of the top
third baseman in the nation as well and
so
something that always helped me was that
even though I got in trouble I was an
athlete and you know athletes in high
school get taken care of they get uh
they get tutors you know they get the
benefit of the doubt with their teachers
they get uh they can take their tests at
different times because they have games
and so their teachers will kind of show
them more leeway so the fact that I was
a baseball player definitely saved my
ass because I was always
[Music]
um
I was always getting into trouble but
they but but I was such a good third
baseman that my coaches would figure out
a way you know to get me out of trouble
and to make sure that I was there on
game day
and so uh
yeah I went back as a junior had a great
junior year I had a great senior year
and I eventually ended up getting a
college scholarship to go play baseball
in college
so uh
the scholarship I got was to a Christian
private school in Fresno I'm a Christian
I was to a Christian private school in
Fresno called Fresno Pacific
and um
Fresno Pacific
um
so I went to a Christian private school
and coming from a high school that was
really like all about partying and drugs
going to a a college program like that I
felt like I went backwards you know I
wasn't allowed to have girls in my dorm
room we had a curfew there was a zero
tolerance policy for alcohol and
drinking and so
like I said I I uh I didn't enjoy this
college that I had chosen to go to and
so I I told you this when I met you the
main theme of my life and my story is
that I feel like there's always this
piano about to fall since I got kicked
out of school as a 16 year old because
um
I feel like there's always this piano
that's about to fall so rather than let
the piano fall and wait in suspense I go
cut the cord right away so at least I
can say I am in control of it it's like
this illusion of controls that I want to
have
and so
[Music]
um
I told you that I didn't really enjoy
the college I had chosen so I started
doing cocaine every single night and uh
I actually got kicked out of college as
a freshman as well for doing cocaine and
ecstasy as a baseball player and so I
got kicked out of high school as a
freshman and I got kicked out of my
first college as a freshman as well both
because I kept it both because I chose
to keep doing drugs instead of
and enjoy the life as an athlete you
know I I was very fortunate to get an
experience that not a lot of people get
in life first of all going to college
I was the first
my dad never went to college so I was
the first man in my family to get a
college degree that was very I'm very
blessed to have that opportunity and not
only that I was very blessed to get the
experience as an athlete in college as
well which you think it's cool in high
school in college you're getting free
gear you're getting you know newspaper
articles written about you and so for me
to [__] that up excuse my language am I
allowed to cuss for me to [__] that up
because I wanted to keep getting high
uh something my dad always taught me was
you can get high when you're 80 90 years
old man you know do it then you do all
the drugs you want because you're you
know at that point you got nothing to
lose but when you're young and you have
this body you know and you're an athlete
you have this opportunity to see
something that not a lot of people get
to do take advantage of that don't
don't take it for granted because one
day you're gonna look back on it and
you're gonna regret it and so I got
kicked out of college as a freshman
um took a year off
went to a city college for another year
and had such a good year as a sophomore
at the city college I got another
scholarship to go play baseball now in
Monterey
and so Monterey I don't know if you've
ever heard of Santa Cruz Santa Cruz is
one of my favorite places in the world
Santa Cruz California
Monterey is an another city near Santa
Cruz and so I got a scholarship to a
division two there called Cal State
Monterey Bay
and uh
[Music]
oh
my God
Blake
um I'm sorry I literally Cal State
Monterey Bay Cal State Monterey Bay yes
okay so I got a scholarship to go play
baseball now at Cal State Monterey Bay I
had one of the greatest years of playing
baseball my whole entire life
um
I then got a scholarship to a division
two in Santa Cruz like I was telling you
called uh Cal State Monterey Bay and
they're known for the aquarium that they
have in Monterey it's one of the nicest
aquariums in California
um it's a little Surfer town you know I
like to call it a stoner town you know a
lot of skateboarders and just it's a
really laid back area and it just so
happens that my parents also have a
house in a place called Capitola there
which is like a really uh bougie
high-class little
um
surf Town that's you know real preppy
and a lot of people of uh that of an
older age demographic live there
and a wealthier age or wealthier
demographic as well but um I went to uh
Cal State Monterey and had two of the
greatest years
um of my life there just overall it was
two years where I actually wasn't deep
in my addiction because I left my
hometown for once and so I wasn't able
to readily get drugs like I always was
when I was in my hometown I I drank a
little bit like a college I drank a
little bit like a college student
normally does you know I smoked weed
here and there but for the most part I
just had a great time living at the
beach and um
experiencing my last two years of
college you know when I look back on it
um
yeah it was two of the best years of my
life because I wasn't
suffering you know a lot when I was
young 16 like I told you I was suffering
from addiction I couldn't stop smoking
weed
to save my life even though it meant my
baseball career I couldn't stop popping
pills even though I wanted to because
I mean I just I just couldn't stop
that's the story of addiction is that
you want to stop
you know on Skid Row there's no one here
that wants to be here there's no one
here that wants I mean barring a few
people you know what I mean in a few
moments
no one wants is here because they chose
to be out here you know what I mean it's
because that
we we suffer from
a disease you know and it's a disease
where you tell yourself that you don't
have a disease that's the saddest part
about it
and so
yeah those two years in Monterey I
didn't feel like I was suffering anymore
you know I was away from home
and
I don't know I get emotional talking
about it because
the last 15 years I mean
I don't know I feel like I've lost
control of my life
there's been a lot of suffering you know
a lot of like loneliness and
when I graduated from college you know I
went and I started working for my dad
as a manager of his company
and uh
I grew up as a welder you know my dad
has a welding company in Fresno the
biggest manufacturing company uh in the
United States
and so I grew up as a welder I started
welding when I was 13 years old welded
to when I was 26 and then when I was 26
I started managing the company I managed
operations for him I which means that I
got the welders what they needed to
build the equipment I would go get the
parts I would organize shipments and
everything whatever I'd set up
everything so they had what they needed
to build the equipment
well during this time I met a girl that
I uh I fell in love with she's a I'm a
hundred percent Armenian that's my my
ethnicity and so that means that I I
need to find a girl who's 100 Armenian
as well
so that way I can continue the bloodline
and our kids are 100 Armenian and yeah
so I met a girl who was Armenian just
like me and it seemed like a match made
in heaven uh this girl was way too good
for me way too good for me she was a
Sunday school teacher she was a 29 year
old virgin and she was
if I am the devil she was an angel you
know what I mean it was like Polar
Opposites and for the first time in my
life she made me wanna do better she
made me want to stop doing drugs she
because
I knew I wanted to marry this girl
[Music]
um I knew that I didn't want to be I
didn't want to be hiding my drug
addiction from her the rest of my life I
didn't want to lie to this girl if I was
going to marry her I had to be honest
and I had to be able to trust her and so
something uh that changed my life
happened uh
I
I for the first time in my life so for
so for 10 to 15 years I had been hiding
my addiction from everyone from my
parents from my girlfriends from my
coaches from my family I always hit it
even though I got kicked out of school I
was always good at hiding it and keeping
my appearance good from the outside well
once I started dating this girl I
decided that I'm gonna tell my family
and I'm gonna tell my girlfriend that I
have been suffering from addiction I've
been taking pills every day going to
work I can't go to work without taking
pills I can't wake up even and get out
of bed unless I take 20 to 40 pills
and um
no all of it
once I told my family that I had an
addiction at first you know they were by
my side they said that they were going
to help me out they sent me to my very
first rehab
and uh I went to rehab I was sober for
one two months and then I realized
and you know they supported me again
sent me to my second rehab where they
were still supporting me and uh went to
my second rehab and
you know two three rehabs go by and the
story of relapse and all of a sudden my
family they don't have hope anymore you
know what I mean they went from very
hopeful to they start reading about
addiction online and the statistics and
all the different things about you're an
addict for your whole life once they
start reading these things they started
to lose hope and uh
yeah when I admitted that I had an
addiction my life changed my house got
sold
um I lost my job I lost my girlfriend I
lost my dog I lost my car I lost it all
I lost everything
and since that day the last two years
I've been going to rehab relapsing
living on the street and
[Music]
I'm in
that's what brought me to Skid Row I was
in rehab three weeks ago three weeks ago
I was in rehab I got kicked out of rehab
for
um for hooking up with a girl in rehab I
got kicked out that rehab was in Orange
County
uh when I got kicked out I came here
that's that's how I ended up here in
skid row and I've been here for three to
four weeks ever since then but it came
from me going to rehab I mean I want I
to this day I still want to be clean I
really do what is your drug my drug of
choice is first of all marijuana like I
said it started with marijuana then it's
opiates
started with Norcos eventually went to
heroin now nowadays it's fentanyl
nowadays fentanyl I smoke heroin at
times or fentanyl when I could find it
you know what I mean but that's
expensive as hell
and then crystal meth
Xanax
the only thing I really don't do is
drink
I've never been a drinker just because
I I don't know why alcohol to me is just
I just don't do it but there's really no
drug that I
I don't do any other addicts in your
family I am the only addict in my family
that I know of I have one Uncle who is
an alcoholic and he now is a born-again
Christian doesn't drink at all but I am
the only addict in my family and that's
the toughest part about it
my it's weird because that's not true my
family
in my culture is full of Alcoholics but
it's different alcoholics are looked at
in vastly different than drug addicts
and that's one of the main differences
is they look at me like I have this
problem but they drink all day even at
work even on Sundays and they don't see
that as a problem it's no different you
know what I mean but I for me to say
that is almost like an excuse to them
you know they don't want to hear it they
don't have a problem it's me that has a
problem
and so uh
yeah yeah it's just it's tough to deal
with because all the information they
have is they have no experience with it
it's all coming from the Internet it's
all coming from what other people say
and man I've tried so hard to [__]
to help them understand what it's like
but
I just I don't I don't know I don't
think they can understand
where are you staying now
right now I'm staying I'm in a tent
staying in a tent on skid row that with
a with someone I just met a couple weeks
ago and
and uh
how are you supporting yourself
there is no supporting myself I haven't
eaten any food in seven days man I just
carried a fridge 10 miles last night
that I found on the street to hopefully
sell it today to get some money to to
hopefully you know what I mean go get
some food and get high but you know the
truth is is that uh this
this opportunity right here was one of
the best things that I could ever do
because
um you know I I want to go back to rehab
I still have insurance I still have
insurance that's really good and so I
want to go back to rehab
you know there's also a bunch of arrests
in my story there's a lot of arrests
that I didn't even mention
and uh you know it's not that they're
important but the fact of the matter is
is that rehab is where I need to be it's
not that I want to
do I want to be in jail no I want to be
in a facility getting better you know
what I mean during my sickness a sick
person should not be in jail a sick
person should be in a hospital or a
facility you know what I mean and so
are you talking to your family
you know
no I haven't spoken to my family and
no I've spoken to him in the last couple
months but
not in the last since I've been a skid
row you know I mean
so
you still have hope of getting your life
together absolutely there's no doubt in
my mind that I'm going to do it you know
I read a quote one time that said
success is
falling down seven times for getting up
eight
you know I could fall down 20 times as
long as I get up 21 times I'm successful
and so
man you know getting being out here
I mean people say you need to hit your
bottom you know what I mean to overcome
this addiction
[__] man there's nothing more I want to
do with drugs I'm over this this isn't
fun anymore this isn't there's no fun
being had doing drugs okay
when I was having look when I had money
that's when I was doing drugs that's
when I was high all the time you're not
high out here on Skid Row none of us
have money none of us are able to even
purchase the drugs that we want to
purchase let alone food or clothes look
at my hands man I haven't showered in
four or five days look at this
sweatshirt you know what I mean look at
my hair look at this beard like I can't
even tell who I am when I look in the
mirror you know if you saw a picture of
me or you saw what I looked like when I
was working and when I was doing it just
it it's it's [__] scary dude
but um
you know this is what drugs does to
people and
you know what's your biggest fear now
my biggest fear is that my mom or my dad
die while I'm out here you know and I
don't get a chance to [__]
be there for him you know or I miss out
on something important because I'm I'm a
family person you know I'm the oldest
like I said of all my brothers and
you know you can't trust anyone out here
man it's [__] terrible dude
by Nature like I'm a good I I want to
help people you know what I mean I wanna
I wanna have relationships with people
but every single person I've had a
relationship with in the last couple of
years has just turned out to [__] me
over man
that's just hard to deal with
like what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
most important lesson I've learned in my
life is that um
I don't know don't take things for
granted because you're not going to get
this time back you know what I mean and
uh I hope I can look back on this time
you know I'm still 29 I'm still young I
hope I look back on this time and say
you know I'm glad I did it when I was
young I'm glad I experienced all that
stuff when I did experience it because I
I could say I got it over with
because I I'd much rather be doing it
now than when I'm 50. I see guys out
here who are
they're done trying you know I mean this
is where they're gonna end up
and
I just want this to be part of my story
pardon my trajectory not where I end up
you know I mean
all right like thank you so much for
sharing your story
I hope you get it all together
thank you so much for this opportunity
and uh I hope I never see you again
thank you